charles bukowski said something in a
poem called style about
art he defined art saying
style is the answer to everything a
fresh way to approach a dull or
dangerous thing to do a dull thing with
style is preferable to doing a dangerous
thing without it
to do a dangerous thing with style is
what i call art
what do you think he meant by that do
you agree with this
a dangerous thing with style is art he
said bullfighting can be hard boxing can
be art loving can be art
uh have you ever made love and it was
art no okay i'm not asking
every time bro
opening a can of sardines can be art
i think there's something to that
yeah i think that i think uh i i call
the way people live life art like i
wrote a forward to my friend cameron
haynes's book and uh which is right now
the number one selling audio book in the
world uh i and i one of the things that
i said was that he practices an art that
very few people appreciate and it's the
art of the maximized life
and that
the discipline that he displays in his
life and through his practices and all
the things that he does
it's so difficult to live the way he
lives
that for someone like me who understands
it and knows what he's doing and
appreciates it and appreciates how
insanely difficult it is to have a
full-time job and run ultra marathons
get up at four o'clock in the morning
run a full marathon before work
like that's the kind of [ __ ] that he he
does when he when he's training for
these
240 mile runs all
the the
at the same time being like a father
um a husband
uh having this full-time job
also being the best bow hunter on earth
lifting weights it's like how is
how does a person do this so in a way
discipline is art too yes it discipline
is art yeah i think it is because it's
beautiful for me to see when i see
someone who's really truly disciplined
who like a david goggin someone who just
like truly maximizes the grind i feel
like there's an art to that and there's
a there's an art to kindness like
there's people that are really kind and
really sweet when i'm around them it's
beautiful it's like there's a art to
them no matter what yeah they still they
got you know the world can throw a bunch
of [ __ ] at you but through all that
some people are just great at it yeah
and it's a
thing that you learn how to do
and it's pleasing for other people to
see and and that i think is where the
art is
well i think mukasky also said
um
and i'm just a bukowski quote generator
today i love him i love him very much
too
uh he's a dark and troubled and
fascinating and a weird person like
hunter s thompson yeah he said what
matters most is how you walk through the
fire i think
so there's a bit of the ken haynes in
that too with david goggins in that too
what do you think he meant by that
well how you walk through the fire i
mean you can walk through the fire
complaining along the way or you can
walk through the fire
and
create an example for everyone else so
that the the
trials and tribulations of their own
life seem trivial because they're
comparing themselves to the way you
handle things or the way you handle
things with grace and dignity and
discipline can show other people
that
they can handle their own life this way
and there's there's beauty in that there
really is and there's so there's so much
so much inspiration to be gathered from
other people if you're a charitable
person if you're charitable and and and
compassionate and you you you can look
at people
even people that i don't like i try to
look at the best aspects of how they
live their life and and
and recognize those aspects admire them
give them credit for it
there's something that we can all get
out of watching the way other people
live their lives
you